November is the perfect month for long nights
at home with your TV, and Amazon is delivering
plenty of entertainment to keep you occupied.
From Jack Ryan and James Bond to Christmas
comedies and Hollywood classics, here are
some fresh new arrivals coming to Amazon Prime
in November.
If you're a James Bond fan and an Amazon Prime
Video subscriber, you're going to be very
pleased with the streaming service this November.
"Mr…?"
"Bond.
James Bond."
Throughout November, Prime's action offerings
will be largely dominated by a certain Agent
007.
Beginning with 1962's Dr. No and ending with
2002's Die Another Day, nearly the entire
James Bond film library will be available
for streaming on Amazon Prime Video on November
1st.
Unfortunately, the additions don't include
any of Daniel Craig's more recent entries,
or the 1967 spoof Casino Royale, but everything
else will be there.
Unless Daniel Craig is your favorite Bond,
you should be very pleased indeed.
Settle in and catch up on all the entries
starring Sean Connery, Roger Moore, Timothy
Dalton, and Pierce Brosnan.
Oh, and George Lazenby's sole contribution,
1969's On Her Majesty's Secret Service, will
be there, too.
The name is Marathon.
James Bond Marathon.
Most viewers know John Krasinski for his portrayal
of Jim Halpert on The Office, and they might
have a tough time buying him as the star of
a political thriller.
Well, let's not be that way.
The first season of Jack Ryan earned plenty
of positive reviews, and Krasinski already
proved he's a versatile actor with A Quiet
Place.
On November 1st, fans will get their second
chance to see Krasinski fight against terrorism,
political corruption, and everything in between.
Jack Ryan's first season had lots of globe-hopping
between the States, Europe, and the Middle
East.
But for the second season, things are going
south.
Ryan travels to South America to investigate
illegal arms sales in the Venezuelan jungle.
His investigation eventually uncovers a vast
conspiracy involving a corrupt Venezuelan
president, secret dealings with Russia, and
the possibility of Venezuela getting its hands
on nuclear weapons.
"We do this, we do this together."
"I can live with that."
Amazon Prime Video added lots of horror movies
at the end of September in preparation for
Halloween.
So if you're tired of the scares, the blood,
and the gore, too bad, because more is on
the way.
On November 1st, Tim Burton's 2007 adaptation
of the stage musical Sweeney Todd: The Demon
Barber of Fleet Street starts streaming.
It stars Johnny Depp as a serial killer-slash-barber
in 19th-century London, who murders his customers
with palpable glee.
Meanwhile, his fiendish co-conspirator, played
by Helena Bonham Carter, turns the dead bodies
into tasty meat pies and feeds them to unsuspecting
customers.
It's deliciously good fun.
If you're still hungry for more abject terror,
the classic 2002 horror film The Ring starts
streaming the same day, and it revolves around
a cursed videotape that kills whoever watches
it.
"Seven days!"
If you're looking for even more gore, prepare
yourself for the 2013 horror film Texas Chainsaw,
which will be showing up on Prime on November
6th.
And if you're on the hunt for more classic
terror, be sure to track down the 1987 thriller
Fatal Attraction, which begins streaming on
November 1st.
Glenn Close stars as Alex, a wildly unhinged
woman whose infatuation with a married man,
played by Michael Douglas, quickly takes a
turn for the psychotic.
After they share a passionate weekend together,
this very married man tries to move on with
his life.
Well, that doesn't go over too well, particularly
for an ill-fated pet rabbit.
"Daddy?"
"What?"
Close's portrayal of the psychotic spurned
lover earned her an Oscar nod - and rightfully
so.
In November, Amazon Prime Video is adding
two Christmas-themed comedies that are a whole
lot darker than your average holiday fare.
On November 1st, the service will start streaming
2003's Bad Santa, a highly irreverent comedy
that stars Billy Bob Thornton as a pitiful,
foul-mouthed mall Santa.
"What about the reindeer?"
"Would you please shut up about reindeer?"
Then, starting on November 13th, you can check
out the 2018 film Anna and the Apocalypse,
starring Ella Hunt as a woman who likes to
sing and dance while killing zombies - occasionally
killing them with humongous candy canes.
Happy holidays!
If you're in no mood for a holiday-themed
laugh riot, check out the 1991 comedy Soapdish
instead.
This brilliant farce offers a hilarious spin
on daytime soap operas - and needless to say,
there's just as much drama going on behind
the scenes as in front of the camera.
The all-star cast includes Robert Downey Jr.,
Whoopi Goldberg, Elisabeth Shue, Sally Field,
and many others.
It's really good stuff.
One of Prime's November offerings with the
shortest turnaround time from screen to stream
is 2018's Creed II, the sequel to the acclaimed
2015 drama Creed.
Michael B. Jordan plays Adonis Creed in both
films - and he's the son of the late boxer
Apollo Creed, played by Carl Weathers.
As you might recall, Apollo died fighting
a juiced-up Soviet boxer in 1985's Rocky IV.
"Don't pretend this is about your father."
Sylvester Stallone reprises his role as Rocky
Balboa, acting as Adonis' trainer.
The second Creed installment sees Adonis face
Viktor Drago, played by Florian Munteanu,
and he's the son of the man who killed Adonis's
father in the ring.
Killer boxer Ivan Drago - played by Dolph
Lundgren - also returns to stand in his son's
corner.
"He needs something to try to turn this fight
around.
Drago just keeps coming!"
And if you're looking for a drama with a bit
more mystery and a way darker ending, there's
the classic 1974 gumshoe mystery Chinatown.
Starring Jack Nicholson as private eye Jake
Gittes and Faye Dunaway as his client, Chinatown
raked in a pile of Oscar nominations, and
even nabbed a win for Best Original Screenplay.
In 1990, Nicholson directed a sequel, The
Two Jakes, but it wasn't nearly as well received
as its predecessor.
Chinatown is absolutely essential viewing,
so be sure to investigate this twisted mystery
if you haven't already.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
TV shows and movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.